[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA GUPTA: Hey, good morning.
I'm Maya from Google AI.
And I'm excited to share
with you about TF Lattice.
This is the same
technology that we
use at Google for
many, dozens really,
of our production models,
where we care about the model
behavior and we
need to make sure
that we can guarantee it's
working sensibly everywhere.
In particular,
we're going to show
how you can control your
models to have monotonicity.
So let me just dive
into an example.
An example I'm
going to use here is
a benchmark dataset
from UCI, so you
could play with this at home.
And we have plenty of data
here, 24,000 training examples.
And there's more
features in the dataset.
We're just going to
look at two, so that we
can visualize what's happening.
And what I'm showing here
is the actual training data.
So the two features are, are
you single or are you married?
And how many months has it
been since you paid your bills?
We're trying to
solve the regression
problem of predicting
are you going
to default on your credit.
So what you can see is that
while there's 24,000 samples,
there's not that many people
who haven't paid their bills
for six months or more.
So we're starting to get
a bit sparse in that part
of the region space.
And what you're seeing
here is the training data,
in the mean and the confidence
interval of the actual training
data.
So what happens when we
go and train a model?
Sort of visualize
what's going to happen.
Is a going to turn
out to be important
if you're single or married?
Not really.
It doesn't matter if
you're single or married,
it really matters how long it's
been since you paid your bills.
But the big surprise
here is the model
believes that it's
better if you've not
paid your bills for seven
months than six months
that you're going to get
a higher credit score.
So this is sad.
This is bad AI behavior.
And this is one of the reasons
that some people don't like AI.
And here we're just
looking at this
in a two-dimensional space.
If we had the full 24
dimensional features
or 30 or 100 features,
there's going
to be pockets of the space
where this sort of thing
may be happening
and we may not even
realize that we're getting this
sort of bad, strange, possibly
unethical behavior
from our model.
So what can we do?
Well, we say, well,
this is overfitting.
Let's just regularize.
But any of your standard
regularization techniques
are going to be problematic.
It's going to be hard to
really fix this without hurting
your model accuracy.
And it's going to be
hard to even check
if you really fixed it.
So what the TF
Lattice package does
is it hits this
problem exactly, and it
lets you have monotonicity
as a regularizer.
You can say when you put
together your features,
for this feature it
should only hurt my model,
it should only hurt my
score if I haven't paid
my bills for a longer time.
And so you can see here,
this fixes that trend
in the high number of months.
And we get the same
flexibility model.
We actually get slightly
better test accuracy,
but we've solved the exact
problem that we need to solve
and we now have a guarantee
on what the model is doing.
And if we had 100 features,
it would similarly
guarantee that in
all those pockets
of 100 dimensional space,
this was working correctly.
So how does TF
Lattice package do it?
Well, under the hood, the kind
of function class it's using
are lattices, and these are
just interpolated lookup tables.
This is possibly the
oldest way humanity
has for representing
function, right?
You've seen these in the
back of your math textbooks.
You can find them in tables from
actuary in 1960s, et cetera.
So in a one-dimensional
space, these are simply
piecewise linear functions.
But with the TF
Lattice package, you
can represent high
dimensional functions also
with these
multidimensional lattices,
multidimensional lookup tables.
Here's an example with
just two features.
We're building a function
with 10 lookup table parameter
values there.
And the lookup table
parameter values
are trained using empirical
risk minimization.
It's all the same training
that you would see with DNN.
It's just the parameters
now represent what's
happening with our function.
And so it's much easier to
control from monotonicity
because there's a lot of
structure to the function
space.
And with the TF
Lattice package, you
can kind of check and choose
how much flexibility you want.
So on the one extreme, you
can just make a linear model.
Very easy to make a
linear model monotonic.
You can generalized
additive models, where
you're using those 1D lattices.
You can do these
multidimensional lattice
models.
If you have a lot
of features, you
may want an ensemble
of lattices.
And we've set this
up with layers,
so you can mix and match and
plug the players with other TF
layers and create sort of
cascade of deep lattice
networks.
Everything in the package
it gives you smoothness.
So compared to
decision trees, you
won't have this sort of
piecewise constant behavior.
You get smooth models
and the monoticity
guarantees that you select.
And here's an example of
five-layer deep lattice
network where these squares
are these 1D calibraters.
And with the launch of
TF 2.0, TF Lattice 2.0
will also be coming
out in a month or two,
and we'll support
Keras layers as well.
OK, so there's a GitHub
link that you can get to.
And there's a nice
set of tutorials
that walks through sort of
all the complexity of what
you might want to do.
Also shows you how to
like layer these things
on top of DNNs for
later layers, et cetera.
The tutorials are
sort of standalone.
You can just work with
them and figure out
how to use this stuff.
If you want to dig into
the technical details,
we have a series of papers.
I'll just point you to
this most recent paper
and you can track
back through some
of the literature from that.
All right, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]